studios are rethinking whether
theatrical releases are worth it make
the case right now for the big silver
TV's fun it's good I've carried memories
that I've seen on television for most of
my life but it's also a disposable
experience there is an aspect about it
being disposable when a movie comes out
that you're interested enough to see and
it makes you leave your house and buy a
ticket and you can do anything in the
world you want that night but you decide
to go to see a film one film particular
and you go to see it and maybe you're on
your own maybe it's in the afternoon or
maybe it's with your date or your wife
or whoever and you go and see it and you
and you buy a ticket and you sit down
and you have an experience and you have
an experience with a bunch of strangers
and at that moment once the movie gets
going once the lights are down you
become a collective and when you have a
good experience it's not always a good
experience but when you have a good
experience those are the things that
stay in your mind and that you remember
for the rest of your life and they
become indelible snapshots okay I'll go
to the movies